[Musique]
j'ai une pression depuis cet après midi
ça a commencé hier on m'a en l'équipe t2
était le dx qu a cessé quand on est venu
me chercher on m'a dit parce que j'avais
un parcours atypique atypique quelqu'un
d'atypique alors bon ça m'a fait sourire
mais au-delà de tout ça je vais je vais
vous dire pourquoi j'ai accepté parce
que c'est la vérité quoi c'est la vérité
moi j'ai pas grand chose à apporter aux
gens mon expérience personnelle
peut-être ce que j'ai vécu ce que ce que
j'ai fait avant pour aider parce que
dans ma démarche on dit changer le monde
mais moi j'ai envie d'aider j'ai envie
d'aider les gens en moi je suis dans une
espèce de rédemption quoi c'est comme ça
mais au-delà de tout ça il ya quelque
chose qui est qui est ici c'est l'esprit
parce que moi je suis je suis un local
je suis un local je suis né à gardanne
voyez je suis né à 15 kilomètres d'ici
six mois si je peux apporter quelque
chose c'est dire quelle que soit notre
destination d'où on vient
son histoire personnelle tout ça c'est
qu'on peut arriver à faire les choses si
on se donne les moyens
oui moi et moi j'ai fréquenté la
voyoucratie marseillaise mais j'étais
pas je n'étais pas préparé à ça
c'est à dire que on se donne on se donne
les moyens de dire oui ou de dire non
alors là où je veux il ya des parents
dans la salle il ya des plus jeunes il
ya des gens de tout horizon mais on est
seul maître de nos décisions
c'est-à-dire ont dit oui où on dit non
et il faut oser le faire
voyez moi je viens je fait l'imbécile je
vous raconte des anecdotes vous rigolez
tout ça mais je vous assure un show
clean moi je prends pas de dope
j'ai toujours refusé de prendre une
substance qui puisse modifier ma manière
d'être mon naturel
voyez que j'arrive je pose ma veste un
je le fais je dis je le ferais où il
savait rien mais j'y vois là je vais
poser ma veste peut-être la baja
récupère après attention
mais voilà mais en tout cas je prends
rien je n'ai jamais voulu un petit verre
de vin de temps en temps mais quand je
le prends je suis amoureux donc
stéphanie elle le sait et puis des fois
elle insiste pour moi faire prendre 2
mais sinon voila je veux pas de
substance je veux dire tout ce qui est
substance à côté tout ça
il faut pas le faire il faut rester
naturel et il faut dire aujourd'hui
malheureusement on est un peu dans une
société où on est pris un peu partout ça
les réseaux sociaux j'en passe et des
meilleurs mais la vraie la vraie vie et
la vraie nature c'est nous c'est la
communication quoi c'est le fait de
communiquer de pas avoir peur de
communiquer quel que soit son origine sa
couleur son milieu social et tout ça moi
moi j'ai fait des choses je suis
populaire moi je viens je suis né à
gardanne d'accord et moi à un moment
j'ai dit oui en fréquentant les voyous
j'ai dit oui j'ai dit oui je vais y
aller alors je suis un passionné moi je
suis un extrémiste moi j'aurais pu aller
très très loin
moi je vais vous dire c'est
contradictoire j'ai été sauvé par un
flic j'ai été sauvé par un policier
jeudi flics mais c'est un policier ma
dernière garde à vue au commissariat
je faisais des bêtises j'ai été j'ai été
très loin dans un petit peu dans ma
démarche parce que j'ai exploré mais
j'ai exploré pas le bon chemin on a des
chemins dans la vie on les choisit on
les choisit pas que vous soyez fils de
rien un fils de docteurs ce que vous
voulez c'est comme ça c'est pas parce
qu'on vient des quartiers nord qu'on est
un voyou ça n'a rien à voir pour être le
fils du maire et vous allez faire des
bêtises parce qu'à un moment vous avez
dit oui donc en fait juste pour revenir
ça la communication est important de
parler parler à vos enfants discuter
entre vous n'ayez aucun sujet tabou
lacam les filles les préservatifs
j'ai postulé au début ça se voit j'ai
regardé ça la répétition c'est le seul
truc qui m'a marqué ou loyers pas l'émoi
que la lumière je le vois et et ça c'est
important
il faut leur parler il faut leur parler
de tout ça il faut leur dire il faut
leur dire ça c'est comme ça si tu fais
ça parce que si vous avez le dialogue et
que vous coupez pas le dialogue
ben le jour où il va faire la bêtise il
va se dire est ce que si je le fais ça
va faire plaisir à mes parents où ça va
pas leur faire plaisir ou peut-être
avant le fait il faudrait peut-être que
je leur en parle après ils n'ont pas
besoin de professeurs moi il ya une
phrase que je dis toujours il n'ya pas
de mauvais élève des mauvais professeurs
c'est souvent ça et est donc on choisit
moi à un moment donné j'ai pris ce
chemin j'ai pris ce chemin et ma
dernière garde à vue au commissariat je
suis tombé le premier inspecteur climat
qui m'a reçu et 1
un ancien si vous voulez un mélange de
lino ventura et michel constantin pour
les plus anciens voyez ce que je veux
dire le gars qui parlait pas trop mais
par contre il y avait des sacrés batas
et qui m'a à kim a d'abord mis un joli
revers et qui m'a qui m'a éclaté la
lèvre ici quoi c'est pour ça que gilles
touré félicien j'avais 18 ans mais moi
en tombant en tombant parce que j'avais
les brasseries ce qu'on appelle les
bracelets quartier en tombant j'ai
récupéré un tiroir qui avait derrière
j'ai raconté ça dans mon livre j'ai
récupéré le tiroir et je suis remis dans
la gueule chose qu'il ne fallait pas
faire parce que quand l'ancien qui était
pas bien d'alès physiquement et pas
costaud parce qu'il n'arrêtait pas de
pomper les cigarettes et joyeux l'excité
avec malev comme ça bien ouverts quand
il a pris le tiroir à travers la figure
et qu'il était par terre ko technique
j'ai dit qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'attendais que ça courait dans couloir
6 10 viennent pour moi alors là j'ai
pris ce que je méritais un une bonne
dérouillée c'était pas la même époque je
vous parle de ça et à 30 ans et à
l'issue de sa je suis resté un petit peu
dans ma dans ma cellule enfin dans la
cellule de garde à vue une cellule de
garde à vue vous savez se sent pas bon
et tout ce qui s'en suit
et là j'ai commencé quand même à
réfléchir j'ai mes tuteurs tu te rends
compte de ce que tu fais quoi j'ai des
frères et des soeurs
g j'avais un potentiel scolaire qui
était intéressant je pouvais faire
quelque chose et je suis là et là je
suis reçue par un inspecteur trentaine
d'années frisé lunettes j'ai jamais revu
ce gars là mais je vous dis frisé
lunettes et il me fait asseoir et ils me
voient une du bon jour il vous voulez un
docteur chez le docteur j dans l'état où
suis-je dit
docteur j'en ai plus besoin je dis là le
truc puis mon lève les bras c'est hélas
on commence à discuter une bille tu sais
je vais schématiser rapidement ah ouais
parce que j'ai la pression j'ai un
chrono aussi un et après vous avez la
pause donc tout ça je le gère j'aurais
jamais fini on va rester peut-être
quatre heures ensemble la pause vous là
et quand il me quand ils me voient comme
ça je mets 18 ans j'ai ce rapport avec
ce gars qui est policier qu'à 30 ans et
puis en fin de compte il me prend il me
prend normalement quoi il parle comme un
être normal et j'avais pas trop là
l'aspect d'un être normal à ce moment là
et mon comportement non plus n'était pas
adapté bon après l'autre est mérité
quand même un petit peu mais il me dit
je vais je vais te dire quelque chose je
résume vite fait il m'a dit voilà le
chemin que tu appris il m'a dit 'il va
se résumer en en deux parties soit tu
finis en prison rapidement d'accord ou
soit c'est la mort voilà moi je suis
d'une génération de l'époque si vous
avez connu pour les vrais marseillais
qui sont ici la french un petit peu donc
l'époque de gate 11 ans pas de francis
le belge ces gens là tout ça je les
connaissais pas je vous rassure on
n'allait pas épiloguer là-dessus mais
voilà c'était un peu ce milieu là où
vous choisissiez bas vous étiez dans un
quartier vous choisissiez soit les stups
soit le vol soit les cambriolages enfin
voilà on vous fournissez y avait un
commercial qui arrive et vous
choisissiez un peu vos cartes là dessus
mais moi je défais par fréquentation
personne personne m'a poussé quoi et il
m'a dit alors je vais te dire quelque
chose est ce que tu as fait ton service
militaire j'ai dit non j'ai pas fait mon
service militaire alors voilà ce que tu
vas faire ou bien tu vas partir cet
après midi à 15h du muet à marseille tu
vas devancé ton appel je reviens avec le
papier comme quoi tu a devancé ton appel
il ya aucune charge n'est retenue contre
toi c'était une histoire de pour vous
rassurer d'histoire cambriolages et rien
qui sera retenu contre toi et tu t'en
vas y lit tu as bien compris et là vous
voyez
je prends conscience dans ma tête comme
ouvre une porte et une fenêtre j'ai 18
ans et pas une question d'âge à
l'ouverture de porte j'ai eu à 50 j'ai
eu à 40 j'en ai 50 3 j'en ai j'en ai eu
à a45 j'en ai eu encore récemment
mais voilà je me lève des barrières et
là on ouvre une fenêtre et puis j'y vais
je pars à la caserne du oui mon frangin
était venu me chercher et j'y mets deux
mois la caserne du bien à marseille
et là bas je fais à l'époque ça
s'appelait un vsl volontaire service
long
je rencontre un gars qui me dis
qu'est-ce que qu'elle subit moi j'ai
perdu mon père très jeune une pensée
pour lui et mon père m'avait dit l'
effet la marine et mon père il était la
marine et il avait été affecté à
l'époque comme mécanicien et les faits
les z'arpètes à saint mandrier et après
il était parti en algérie à la base et
comme la base des fusiliers marins
mais moi je pensais qu'ils étaient
fusillés marins mais il était mécanicien
enclins à boire mais quand je suis
arrivé là-bas le mdi alors qu'est-ce
qu'on les ferme jeudi la marine
d'accord je boxais un petit peu à
l'époque à l'époque de gratien tonna
pour ce qu'ont connues c'est quand même
un monsieur en boxe et tout ça et puis
il me dit la marine et il me dit je veux
partir le plus longtemps possible
eh bien il me dit un vsl volontaire
service long et puis j'ai signé
j'ai fait moi une attestation il faut
que je retourne voir quelqu'un avec le
papier je suis parti là-bas je vais
raconter parce qu'à l'école de mon
grand-père les marrons d'après là-dessus
aussi jeu je renvoie le papier au
commissaire il me dit c'est très bien tu
peux partir mais je te vois plus ici
plus jamais ici je dis ok une minute ça
veut dire qu'il me reste j'ai pas fini
un vosgien
je reçois une semaine après un papier à
la maison départ pour lorient ma mère
qui prend le papier dit tu t'en vas à
l'étranger
toute la famille sur la carte regarder
où étaient lorient parce que lorient
c'est dans le morbihan 56
mais mon grand père m'a même pour seul
et marseille et qu'on connut pearl
fourrure à marseille rue saint ferréol
et machete une toque comme ça avec un
truc qu'on rabattaient sur les oreilles
avec la fourrure
parce qu'il dit là où il fait très froid
je vous assure que c'est vrai je vais je
vais toujours j'ai toujours ce chapeau
je ne mets pas mais j'ai toujours ce
chapeau et je pars et quand j'arrive là
haut on est accueilli à la gare par un
maître puisque après après 22 ans de
service je connais quand même un peu les
grades non je pourrais dire un géant il
s'appelait m berre
il est plus de ce monde dieu ait son âme
et il avait une tête d'ogives bien
pointues comme ça à raser et quand on
descend du train je vous assure je me
prenais encore pour un caïd un mois j'ai
été bercé par scarface al pacino et tout
ça et je croyais que le monde c'était ce
à quoi rien à voir avec ça c'est pas la
vraie vie je rassure tout le monde les
fictions et tout ça à facebook
les films c'est du cinéma quoi déjà pour
ici avec un arbre de faire ça bang bang
être en cible vous pouvez y aller je
vous le dis avec l'expérience ça
n'existe pas et j'y arrive là-bas la
gare il nous amène sur lorient
arrivé sur lorient on rentre dans la
base des cols des fusillés on est à peu
près trois bus donc 45 places vous voyez
les trois bus on descend hélas ce maître
bayer il nous fait un discours il nous
dit voilà vous voyez là vous êtes dans
le monde civil on était sur la base y
avait un grand gymnase et là il y avait
un couloir et il dit du monde civil vous
allez passer dans ce couloir dans ce
couloir vous êtes libre si vous avez sur
vous de la drogue des armes vous pouvez
tout mais il ya deux caisses qui sont là
ça nous regarde pas tout ça ça partira à
la poubelle ça sera viré tout ça par
contre si vous acceptez de passer ce
couloir que vous basculer de l'autre
côté
après vous êtes à nous et vous êtes chez
nous et quand vous avez cent cinquante
personnes comme ça rassembler et qu'on
vous dit ça à moi le premier moi le
premier j'ai pris conscience j'ai fait
la démarche caserne du muy je suis parti
je vais à lorient
j'avais pas mis mes pieds en bretagne je
connaissais pas la bretagne bretagne et
le couloir ça veut dire qu encore on
donne une chance on me dit vas-y dans ce
couloir vas-y j'arrive dans ce couloir à
l'époque j'avais 1
une arme factice un truc d'alarmé armin
us à l'époque et puis je suis arrivé là
bas j'ai pris le petit pistolet d'alarmé
je les ai mis dans la caisse dans la
caisse avec toi là je peux vous dire que
il y avait il y avait du matos 1 quand
même et là et je suis sorti de l'autre
côté
et là j'ai fait 22 ans 22 ans
mais pourquoi je les ai faits après ses
22 ans je me prenais pour un caïd je me
prenais pour un costaud chaque fois que
j'avais quelque chose à faire on disait
c'est pas avec ta force et avec des
points c'est pas ta grande gueule tu
cours tu travailles tu es cours tu finis
premier tour à ce que tu veux à chaque
fois quand j'ai fait mon stage commando
élémentaire je vais finir par ça parce
qu'après vous mettre une alarme
quand j'ai fait mon stage co élémentaire
j'ai fini major pour la première fois de
ma vie
vingt ans
pour la première fois de ma vie j'étais
premier quelque part c'est en fait
l'individu
je me mets à poils ce soir devant moi
l'individu il faut le valoriser
on s'est trop faire quand on dit c'est
pas bien tu as fait une bêtise tu fais
quelque chose tu t'es là dans le monde
du travail dans le monde de la vie de
tous les jours mais quand c'est bien dit
le dites le à quelqu'un c'est bien ce
que tu as fait quel que soit le métier
quels que soient expliquées décoder dit
que c'est bien moi pour la première fois
de ma vie
on savait pas le résultat on était
rassemblée on avait commencé peut-être à
50 personnes et on était douze ou treize
à rester quand il a annoncé mon nom
matelot arrive on sortait des rangs qui
m'a remis la dague
il m'a dit major du stage commando 59
pour la première fois de ma vie je me
suis sentie important là cette
importance elle m'a permis de m'épanouir
de mais ça c'est sympa à faire c'est le
tourmalet je m'appelle ça
elle m'a permis de m'épanouir de
m'épanouir et de comprendre dans les
livres d'histoire à l'école on l'a
jamais appris on l'apprenait pas j'ai
fait deux fois instructeur au stage
commando à l'époque à lorient pendant le
débarquement 177 français béret vert ont
débarqué en normandie en 44 c'était des
français des bretons des marseillais de
ce que vous voulez qu'on traversait la
manche qui sont passés par l'espagne
qu'on rejoint là bas france et pardon
pour venir débarqué c'est quand j'ai
compris ça j'aurais pu tomber sur un bon
maçon j'aurais pu tomber sur un bon un
fermier qui m'aurait donné il ya des
choses qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
la remise en question elle est
importante
chaque étape de sa vie il faut se
remettre en question la communication
est importante il faut parler avec ses
enfants il faut pas aller que ses
collaborateurs
l'humilité il faut être humble humble
avec soi-même humble avec les autres
humble dans la vie c'est important que
vous soyez tout en haut du sommet vous
redescendez vite en bas je vous dis je
vous dis pas ce que c'est c'est quelque
chose qui est important et si vous avez
compris ça on peut y arriver parce que
tout est possible
volonté détermination à voir en vie et
être humain bordel
soyez humains humains et valoriser les
gens faites le si vous avez oublié de le
faire quand vous partez le matin ma
philosophie vous avez su c'est ne pas
encourager un homme parce qu'il a fait
une erreur c'est l'empêcher de
s'améliorer c'est ça faut jamais
partisan de la double peine
tu as fait une connerie tu prends un
coup de pied au cul maintenant tu vas
trop mètres dans l'axé tu vas travailler
tu va montrer de quoi tu es capable
quand il a montré de quoi il était
capable et bien là on y va et on l'aide
ça c'est important
chaque matin où je me lève ma
philosophie j'imagine que c'est mon
dernier jour
d'accord je me dis chaque matin où je me
lève je vais mourir peut-être
aujourd'hui j'en profite
j'en profite au maximum j'embrasse mes
enfants j'ai un bout que j'ai pris des
risques ce soir j'ai invité ma drh
j'ai pris des risques mais chaque matin
où je me lève je me dis c'est ça j'ai
des ennuis dans le boulot et tout ce qui
s'ensuit mais je me dis non je vais y
arriver je vais y arriver fait le c'est
pas impossible et c'est pas parce qu'on
vient d'un quartier c'est pas parce
qu'on vient d'un endroit parce qu'on est
issu d'une classe sociale ou autre chose
parce qu'on est d'une origine ou autre
chose
on peut y arriver si on se donne si on
veut dire voilà mon moi mon message et
un mois changer le monde moi mon petit
message à moi avec mon petit niveau
c'est changer changer le monde et bien
il faut le faire voilà ça c'est une
partie de ma conclusion j'ai pas fini il
reste encore du temps et j'ai pas fini
je vais je vais finir non je vais finir
je vais finir par une chose par deux
choses de choses
la première parce que c'est filmé sur
youtube tout ce qui s'ensuit et je
voudrais dire à ma mère que je les aime
voilà maintenant je t'aime parce que
parce que quand j'ai écrit mon livre je
n'ai pas épargné dans mon livre parce
que j'ai écrit mon livre avec ma faculté
d'écriture et emma syntaxe d'aujourd'hui
mais avec mon coeur d'enfant à l'époque
et donc elle a pu être touché par mon
livre en se disant mais je suis pas se
tenir là mais je voulais qu'elle le
sache et je laime j'aime ma mère est et
grâce à elle je t'aime maman comme celle
l'opération youtube elle dira ok et la
deuxième je vais chanter quelque chose
en mémoire à mes camarades mes amis tout
ça je vais chanter un petit refrain
c'est pas morales mais parce que
stéphanie qui est dans la salle croyait
pas que j'allais le faire d'ici à la fin
parce qu'au début j'ai chanté alors j'y
vais justement et je finirai par chu ni
à part ça c'est la chanson va quatrième
escouade de montfort mais je chante que
le premier refrain la première partie et
après le refrain mais ça dure quelques
secondes
hamon informant que m'importe la gloire
les lois du monde comme importe la mort
sur l'océan j'ai planté ma victoire est
bon à mon vin dans une coupe d'or vivre
d'amour et ma seule espérance le seul
bonheur que j'ai su conquérir
si sur les flots j'ai passé mon enfance
c'est sur les flots qu'un forban doit
mouiller
ir va qui pétillent femme gentille
ajouté baiser brûlant d'amour il à bhl
plaisir bataille qui va canaille je vois
je chante et je tue tour à tour merci à
vous